але ж ти не основа була запрошена режим
при понині обігнемо
вона стріляні на озоні конфлікту
продовжуєте хто порушив режим тисяч
нато , ні в сочі душі складно дати
відповід там шукаю ваш коваля ти з
чого владні патча собі
харчування раніше в тому
готові чоп творить і зону без пепі через
всередині після підписання мінських догляд
весь до сочі навантажує сьогодні до 1 мені
ція ваш до відразу мід і
ти автоматично зуму вліпить висікти не
напруги все знову робить про нові
боїв теж за місцем зони без піку моєму
зону з новим і на bespeco мем це саме
причому миску не додавалася і все кашель
люди чиї сиві ван і убихії про
допомогу указом літаючий вудлище занадто
сиф по б два блоки або не визе на не
кажуть 1 ти сам і ми хочемо висновок
всього безумство ми хочемо mckinsey шпалер
ми хочемо видалити ж ти вже нормальний
team ті люди хоче зал і хитайся так
званих днр і лнр че хоче жити в Україні
люди каже нам ми українці їм ви покарають
Мене сепаратисти
вчителю доведу, що хоче жити і так як
це було до конфлікту ми почали люди
ще он з найкращими за лашет освоїли
днями себе через так дзвони днр і лнр
причина скло і люди цокають критично
економічна ситуація там органи і йдуть
ще знає і нові game by andy яка у
тіні ітар мови я кому пит даєте спершу
убитий деякими цим ніж а це ви хлопці
гарантії баскети адже так званих днр і
лнр
vegas наші мандат і мій повний
свободу за малюванням і бавитися
мігранта вати про дві сторони то їх
німецького та карим листя c ви знають та
мінську біля води тарифи не без п'яти
шести дуже високою вище та шістнадцятого
Січ не вивчили в одну з наших машин
кусали мар'їнка
а все можу сич її в горлі в сенат нашу
групу з надлишку волосся та противники
так званої днр порину з бровою наших
постріляти і поклали на землю валовим
з них заламали руки за спину та й
кулінарний вигляд викликає у себе через
приводи
інцидент був вичерпаний а дорівнює чітко
демонструючи козара ситуація все ви че
різаки та меншими можна помалювати ще
менше ми переселяємося темі та вирішили
ікона йому свою місію
але морізо цілому індійський бейкер боїться